And he asked you to expect it right over here.
From those observations you would say that the velocity
points in the direction of this vector.
Assuming no drastic change in velocity,
you expect that the 5th position would be over here.
The common filter takes observations like these
and estimates future locations and velocities based on data like this.
Today I'm going to teach you how to write a piece of software
that let's you take points like those--even if they're noisy and uncertain--
and estimate automatically where future locations might be
and at what velocity the object is moving.
The Google self-driving car uses methods like these to understand
where other traffic is based on radar and laser-range data.
So let's dive in!